Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry I'm late!
Oh, my God!
I'm sorry, everybody.
So, yeah, I think we all know why I'm late.
So, I'm really sorry, guys.
I really... I needed... I needed more time.
I needed to, like, you know, re-situate myself and I just needed... I needed more time to process everything that fucking happened today.
So, I'm sorry.
I really appreciate everyone for being so patient with me.
And, like, I'm sorry.
I know I'm like... I know I'm like an hour... I'm really... I really appreciate Cookie Run for waiting it out for me.
I really, really appreciate... Thank you, Cookie Run!
And thank you, everybody, for, like, gassing me up and glazing me.
And thank you, guys.
Guys, we all love Cookie Run, right?
We all... Oh, man.
You guys already clicked the download link already, right?
Oh, you guys just saw me... You saw me.
You're like, oh, my gosh, JoeKeeper's gonna be playing Cookie Run?
That's enough of an endorsement for me.
I'm gonna even... I'm gonna download that game right now without watching a stream yet.
That's how much I believe in her.
Right, guys?
Right?
Oh, my God.
Anyway, so, if you guys didn't know, this is not our very... This is not our first time playing Cookie Run.
Cookie Run actually sponsored me a couple of months back.
And they loved the sponsored stream from last time, you know, when I started, like, beating up the children in-game.
In-game.
When I started using the most overpowered characters, I saw those little babies, and I was like, that's right, I'm gonna teach you a lesson with my one character.
And they're like, we like that.
Let's get her again.
And I was like, oh, man, I don't even know if they're gonna get me back after I did that.
They're like, we like this stream.
Alright, we're gonna get her again.
Anyway, oh, yeah, I'll use Tails.
You guys were like, use Sonic!
And I was like, no, I'm gonna use Tails.
I'm gonna feed Tails everything I have.
That's not even my money.
I'm gonna use this guy's- all their money and just fucking- oh, sorry, just freaking- Oh my god, I'm sorry, I'm a mess right now.
I'm gonna feed him, I'm gonna buff Tails.
And they're gonna be like, oh my god, who beat me?
Who beat my team?
And then all they see is one cookie and it's Tails.
Not even an A-tier character, it's just Tails.
Hey guys, huge shoutout to Cookie Run for the sponsor.
I know everything was a little bit poor timing.
So I really appreciate your patience for waiting an hour for me to do this stream.
I really appreciate it, guys.
So for those who don't know, apparently it is Cookie Run's 4th year anniversary.
So there's a lot of new updates, there's a lot of new characters to pull, there's a lot of new things that happened in between the last Cookie Run sponsor to this Cookie Run sponsor.
So there's a lot of neat things to check out.
I'm always gonna be super in awe and surprised because, like I said, it's been a while since the last time I played Cookie Run was a couple of days after the sponsor.
And honestly, I really do enjoy it.
I think one of my favorite things about Cookie Run, Cookie Run Kingdom and their branding and the universe of Cookie Run is just the character designs are really pretty.
I have to admit, they have really nice character designs and yeah, I'm super looking forward to it.
I think when I logged in, I don't think there was cinematic, so let's watch the cinematic.
Also, I don't know if the sound guy is around right now.
So this is the new character.
I believe his name is Shadow Milk.
It's a bit loud, let me turn it down.
Oh,
I love the music.
Why wasn't I?
I wish I was a competitive Cookie Run player.
To bring... yeah, I want to do that app in the settings.
You're right, it's never too late.
You're right.
Can I keep this account?
You're right, can I keep this account?
We all need a head start.
This could be my head start.
Why can't Cookie Run have VTubers?
Honestly, if Cookie Run has like a VTuber...
Guys, they're nuking this account, right?
Okay, I was told they will nuke this account when the stream ends.
But they can't nuke it if the stream never ends.
My competitive arc starts now.
They can't do anything if I just never close end the stream.
That's right.
I'm still finding loopholes even though the loopholes end up fucking me over.
I'm still finding loopholes.
I never learn.
The Doki Bird Suppathon of only competitive Cookie Run starts now.
It's just Cookie Run.
Nothing else.
I just never stop the stream.
This account is mine now.
They can't.
They said they'll only nuke the account after the stream is over.
They can't do that if I just never end the stream.
That's illegal.
Okay, so that's one of the Shadow Milk Cookie.
That's one of the new designs.
And there's also Candy Apple Cookie.
Oh my god, they're all so cute.
And then, oh, there's like the Muse Season.
Explore makes the game more fun.
Wait, oh yeah, there was a Halloween update too.
But yeah, there is a lot of new things.
Not new updates because it's the 4th year anniversary.
So I'm not surprised because it is the 4th year anniversary.
And usually during anniversary years, they tend to release a lot of cool stuff.
Yeah, I really like the design.
Choose areas that each beast is occupying to vanquish them and proceed with the story.
Okay.
Okay, I want to... let's see.
I want... okay, guys.
Because it's my account now.
Let me change the name.
It's my account now.
It's my kingdom now.
That's right.
What can you do now?
You can't delete this account.
It's mine now.
How could you delete the account if it's mine?
That's right.
What are you going to do now?
It's mine.
I yoink this kingdom.
I shall...
But it's not...
Yeah, so they won't know.
They won't know it's me.
You're right.
I'm going to change the password.
No, it's not going to stop them from deleting the account.
That's right, guys.
How can they take...
How can they take the account if I usurped the account, guys?
How could they?
Checkmate.
Yeah, exactly.
They will assume I would name my account after me.
So they don't know that it's not Doki.
That's right.
Oh, it's three steps ahead.
Look at my beautiful...
Oh, hey, look.
There's Donald.
Look at my beautiful kingdom that I worked so hard.
Look at that.
My beautiful kingdom...
that I worked so incredibly hard on.
This is where my competitive cookie run...
My competitive cookie run arc starts now.
It actually started...
You know, I've had this account for like a couple of years now.
So I'm really happy that I'm able to showcase this account that is totally mine.
Legitimately mine.
And I was very happy.
Yeah, I grinded...
I grinded all of this.
I know, I know.
I managed to grind all of this off stream.
And like I said, I legitimately own this account.
And because this is legitimately my account...
Obviously, I get to keep this after the stream.
Right, guys?
Oh my god, all this hard work.
Oh my god, 31,522 jellies guys.
That I totally earned myself.
You shouldn't have.
I was there for all of this.
Okay, where is the...
I know where the volume is, guys.
Gosh.
I played this game for so long.
Of course I know where it is.
Guys, of course I do.
Okay, now I just need to boost up the volume a little bit.
Alright, this is sponsored.
That's why I love Cookie Run so much.
Alright, so...
I believe there is...
Oh my god, I feel like there's so many more things now.
For the 4th year anniversary.
Let's see, what do they have?
Ooh, toppings.
I wanna know.
What login bonus do I get?
January 18th, searing raspberry.
Oh my god, that is a lot.
That is...
Whoa, okay.
There's a lot of rewards.
There's the topping.
Oh, there it is.
What do I get?
Ooh, I'll get some jelly beans.
Ooh, I got new update gifts.
Ooh.
And then I get tickets to join the cookie...
Oh wait, I'll just claim it all.
I feel like...
Oh my god, there's a lot, okay.
Alright, there's...
Okay.
Make your choice, guys.
Which one?
Do I get the 30 pristine powder?
Or the...
Oh wait, they're all different stats.
You know what?
Attack is the best defense.
There you go.
Pristine charge power.
Yeah, let's get it four times.
That's right.
Nice.
Like I always say...
Attack is the best defense.
Let's go, I love free stuff.
I worked so hard for these three things.
Like...
Oh my god.
I can see how people can get very addicted.
Since I'm one of them.
I mean, it took me a long time to...
Grind my way up here on my not-doki account.
Sound, guys.
All the sound.
Lots of hard work.
Yeah, there's lots of bonus items and everything.
Because like I said, it is the fourth year anniversary.
So...
There is a lot of like bonus items that comes with logging in today.
And like the next couple of days for the fourth year anniversary.
So honestly, it is like the best time to start playing Cookie Run.
Because we all like free stuff.
As always.
I mean, not me.
I like hard work and...
Sorry.
I also love free stuff.
But you know what I like even more?
As you see from my town.
Hard work and determination to build up a town like this.
But of course, building up a beautiful town like mine...
Takes a couple of months of hard grinding.
So you gotta keep playing.
But you also gotta thank me too.
And be like...
Wow, thank you Doki Bird for introducing me to Cookie Run Kingdom.
And letting me have a town that's just as beautiful as yours.
Not Doki account.
But yes, there are some coupons that will be coming out on multiple social media channels.
So please follow Cookie Run Kingdom on Twitter.
And like, subscribe to them on YouTube to grab some of these coupon codes.
Alright.
Let's do our favorite thing.
Okay.
4th year anniversary lot.
Woah.
There's a lot of things in the shop.
The update package $3.99.
Oh my god, is it...
Shit.
I'm rich.
Of course I'm rich.
I grinded for this for so long.
You can let other players hire your cookies?
Isn't that awesome?
Oh my god, I can have other people pay me?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Alright, hire...
Hire... get weekly rewards if your cookie gets hired a lot.
You can... wait.
Who are the most demanded cookies?
I hope I'll earn my place on that list one day.
See this button?
You pick the cookie.
You can tap it.
There's a reward for registering your cookie for...
Don't forget to claim it.
Guys, who is the most in demand cookie out there?
Oh my god, it has to be Tails, right?
Guys.
Guys, hire my Tails cookie.
He's been through so much.
Alright, I'm gonna claim.
Alright, surely...
Surely, Tails is the most requested.
I made him look so broken.
Surely, he has to be the...
There's no way he isn't.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright.
Surely, he has to be the most requested cookie out there.
No gear.
He doesn't need gear.
He's so good already.
I already made him look so broken.
Alright.
It's time to do our favorite...
Oh, did I do it?
Wait.
That's it?
Oh no, this is the new one!
I was like, oh my god, did I do it?
That was so...
Alright, let's see.
We can do this.
I believe we can, like, first try.
It was just...
No, that's...
I was like, oh my god, I did it!
I was like, wow!
Man, I am so good at this game.
Alright, it'll be fine.
I'm pretty sure I can first try this.
There's no way.
I'm so scared you broke the game in one roll.
Alright, let's get him.
Oh, hey, it's red!
Is that it?
Is that him?
No way!
Oh!
Wait, that's common.
Okay, I was gonna be like...
Okay, I got pancake cookie soul core.
Did I do it?
Is that him?
Wait, no.
Who's that?
Rye cookie.
No!
My streamer luck didn't hit it!
Who are you?
Wait, it is me though.
Wait, I got me though.
Yay, I got me!
Oh, wait.
Is the voiceover not on?
Sorry, I played this game so often that I forgot to turn voiceover on.
Okay, wait.
Alright, let's see.
Where's the voice set?
I thought it was on.
Skill video on.
Yeah, it is!
It is on.
Why he no talk to me?
Why didn't he talk?
How could he?
I can't believe he didn't talk to me!
He hates you.
Well, it should be on.
Yeah, it's on English.
Oh, wait.
There was no voiceover though.
I was listening to it.
What?
Who said that?
Alright, it's the second poll.
It's always the second poll.
I lied.
It wasn't the first poll.
It's always the second poll, guys.
Wait, this has to be it.
Come on.
Give me a rip.
Oh my God.
Wait, that's two.
Wait, I got two.
It's not?
Wait, but look!
It's sparkling!
What is that?
I'm gonna pinch your cheeks.
I'm gonna pinch them.
Oh my God, okay.
Okay, he's pretty cute.
I already got this cookie.
That's why he's not talking to me.
He's like, you already have me.
I don't want to talk to you.
I'm too lazy to talk to you again.
Who's this?
It's this guy?
Rockstar Cookie.
I like how he's a heal.
He's a medic.
Oh my God, he's so cool.
Look at this beautiful, luscious whipped cream.
Oh my God.
I wonder if he like...
Technically, since he's a cookie, you can like slurp up his whipped cream and then make him bald.
Technically.
This music saved my life.
Three epic pulls.
Three epics and 20 pulls.
What, like it's hard?
I mean...
If you're like a gamer like me, it's just every day.
You know?
It's just an average jokey day.
Oh yeah, I already got them.
So like...
So they don't talk to me.
They got too lazy to talk.
Alright.
I'm bringing up the overall a little bit more.
Okay, we don't care.
No!
What do you mean all commons?
What do you mean?
Oh my God, we don't even look at them.
They're worthless to me.
Alright, this is okay.
Now, now this is where we get Shadow Milk.
This is it.
It's so easy, guys.
Look, she's giving me the eyes.
That's when we know.
See?
Okay, there he is.
There he is.
That's Shadow Milk right there.
Right there.
Oh, oh, and it's...
Oh, there's the galaxy!
That has to be Shadow Milk.
Who else could it be?
Okay, we don't care.
We don't care.
Is it him?
We already got Shadow Milk.
Wait.
Do I already have...
What?
Wait, what?
No?
Oh, it's a soul store.
A soul.
Oh.
Did I just get me?
Oh, wait, no.
That's not me.
Okay.
That's not me, right?
Did I just get me again?
Did I just get...
Wait.
Oh.
The royal...
Oh, my God.
That's almost...
That's...
I got Dragoon!
He's so...
Oh, my God.
I got a Drag...
Wait, that's not fair.
That's like two cookies.
That's...
Why does he get to be two?
Oh, if you get 20, you unlock him.
Oh, I was gonna be like, there's no way.
Do I already...
That felt so anticlimactic.
If I already have him...
I was like, there's no way.
Okay.
Okay, the next pull is where we actually get him.
The next pull is it, guys.
It's always the next pull.
Your mom lets you have two cookies?
No, she didn't give me the eyes.
No!
Okay, the next pull, guys.
Sorry.
Sorry, my eyes were...
Sorry, my game crashed.
So, that pull didn't count.
The next pull is where it's at.
Let's go gambling.
No, okay.
Okay, sorry.
My game...
Sorry.
There's no way.
Was it all a comment?
She didn't give me the eyes!
I don't understand.
I...
Okay, it's...
Wait, extra rewards?
Guarant...
Shall milk cookie guaranteed for beast pulls?
Reward cleared?
Oh!
I got...
Guys, guys!
The only reason why...
I didn't get shadow milk yet...
Is because...
Okay, why?
Okay, the...
Okay, the only reason why...
I didn't get shadow milk yet...
Is cause...
I'm not here for shadow milk.
I'm here for the rewards.
I wanna max out my level rewards first...
Before...
I actually want shadow milk.
Cause it's like...
What's the point?
All I'm saying is...
What's the point of getting shadow milk so fast...
If I don't get the free rewards that come with leveling up from pulls?
I think that's like the strat, you know?
As a competitive cookie run kingdom gamer...
That's how you should play the game.
That's the real strat of...
I don't know.
I mean, like...
I mean, do you have a kingdom like this?
I don't know.
I mean...
How else do you think I managed to build up a kingdom...
As beautiful as this?
Guys...
How else, guys?
Look, I have Donald Duck.
Does your kingdom have Donald Duck?
I don't think so.
That's right.
Does your kingdom have...
Okay...
Sorbet Shark Cookie?
That's level 80?
I don't think so.
So it's like...
Oh yeah, I do.
Does your kingdom have...
Whatever the hell this guy...
What are you?
Angel Cookie...
Oh my god, that...
I guess...
Is that what...
Why are you a...
Oh my god, okay.
Why are you...
Why do you look like that?
Why...
Okay.
Anyway, here we go.
Oh my god, where are my eyes?
Please, witch!
Where are my eyes?
I can't say that.
Oh, oh!
She's giving me the eyes.
This has to be it.
Biblically accurate cookie.
There's no way.
This has to be...
This has to be him.
This has to be Shadow Milk Cookie.
She gave me the eyes.
That's when you know.
Okay, that's the soul stone.
That's the soul core.
Purple yum cookie.
This has to be it, right?
Wait, what?
Was that it?
No, this has to be it.
This has to be him.
Who the heck is this guy?
Milk cookie.
What?
Oh my god.
Instead of...
Instead of Shadow Milk, it gave me milk.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, my request got lagged.
Just milk.
No!
The cookie gods only got half of my message.
It's okay, guys.
Guys, like I said, this trap...
The strat was to get as much pulls as I can.
So I can farm the free rewards, guys.
That's always been the strat, guys.
My mic got cut off.
They're like, oh, you mean milk cookie?
Don't worry, I got you, bro.
Oh my god, okay.
That's fine.
I've always wanted two buff cookies.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, the eyes.
The eyes.
That has to be it.
Okay.
No, we're not pulling the pity, guys.
It's not the pity.
We're not getting them out of pity.
We're getting them via pure skill.
Okay.
Soul core.
Okay, this has to be him, right?
No, that's just...
Oh, wait.
What?
He's a squirrel!
Oh my...
I've always loved these types of hoodies.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's so cute.
He's like a little squirrel.
I wanna bite his head off.
Oh my god.
I just wanna...
I wanna be like...
Nom, nom, nom.
Hahaha.
When you ever feel like something's just so cute that you gotta eat it?
Who are you?
Cut me off, Kirky.
I...
I don't understand!
Alright, guys.
How many pulls does it take to hit pity?
Where am I at, guys?
Guys, I need to know.
Where am I at before I hit pity?
Guys, where am I at before I hit pity?
But how many pulls do I have left?
How many pulls?
13 more?
Okay, guys.
There's no way.
I do not get to pity.
The cookie gods are surely not cruel.
The cookie gods surely cannot be this cruel at me.
Oh!
Wait!
That has to be it!
She had angry eyes!
Wait, what?
Wait, what does that mean?
Wait.
What does that mean?
What does the...
What does the spicy eyes mean?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Oh, it's only rare.
I got baited.
I got so baited.
I was like, oh my god!
The spicy eyes!
She has something spicy for me.
Angry eyes not good.
No!
Why?
Wait, that's me.
That's me.
Okay.
Alright.
This has to be.
We still have 10 more pulls before it's pity.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm just in a rut.
I'm just in a rut right now.
But like, it can only go up now.
I've hit bottom.
Guys, it's alright.
I've just hit rock bottom, but it can only go up from now, right?
It can only get up right from now, guys.
Why are you so angry?
What have I done to you?
All I do is give her money.
What have I done to her?
I give you all my money.
What else do you want more?
What more do you want?
Today's been a very bad day, okay?
Oh my god.
Why does it keep going?
You ungrateful witch.
I knew we should have burned her.
I never trust the witches.
I've known since yesterday's God of War.
Never trust witches.
We should have just burned her.
Burned her at the stake.
And just steal her.
I don't understand.
Why don't we just steal her cookbook and make our own cookies?
We don't need her.
Do we really need her?
Okay, how many pulls do I have left, guys, before I hit pity?
Yes, how many pulls left until I hit pity?
Okay, six more.
Guys, we're gonna hit it.
We're gonna hit it, guys.
Wait, 40?
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
It's okay.
We still have...
We can make it.
We will get it before we hit the pity system.
I believe.
It's okay.
We're gonna hit it.
There's no way.
You're all out to get me.
They're actually...
The entire world...
Today has...
Oh my god, the entire world is out.
No, I have one left.
Oh no.
I've never seen anyone hit R.
Don't say that.
No, don't say that.
That's okay.
Now, don't worry.
We're doing ones now.
That's when we know.
Okay.
So we can, you know, increase the anticipation.
We pull it one by one.
No, we're not gonna hit R.
We have to hit our pity.
If I pull it one by one...
Yes, queen.
Cast light yourself.
There's no way.
If I do it one by one...
If I...
Queen, I'm stalling.
No, guys.
If I do it one by one, surely I can get it before I hit heart pity.
Come on, give me the eyes, you old witch.
I'm lighting up.
I'm lighting up my torch right now.
Come on.
Give me those eyes.
Oh no, I have four more pulls.
Come on.
You know you want to.
Just give me...
Oh my god, have I ever told you how beautiful you look today, miss witch?
Have I...
Light the pitchforks.
Guys, get ready.
We're gonna form an angry mob.
Guys, it's okay.
We're gonna get it.
No, no, no.
Oh my god.
You look so...
Any other eyes?
Why can't you have any other eyes?
I...
Why?
You stupid gumball cookie.
Guys.
Toki's luck died so yours did.
How about if I never... Guys, if I never do the final pull, we might never know if I got it or not.
If we never do the final pull, maybe we'll never know.
We'll never know.
Wow.
99% of gattlers quit before they hit it big.
Oh my god.
And she still kissed me in the eye.
I'm gonna banish this cookie from my world.
Give me a sec.
What's her name?
Carrot cookie?
That's her name, right?
I'm gonna...
Where is she?
Where is carrot cookie?
She no longer lives in my kingdom.
She...
What did she do for existing in my kingdom?
I shall banish you.
Alright, how am I... I'm gonna find you.
Guys.
What's... I'm gonna find you.
Where are you?
How do I find her?
How do I find her in my kingdom?
No, it was the witch's fault.
Not hers!
No!
Dashboard!
Oh,
it's so over for you.
Where's the dashboard?
I definitely know where it is.
No, don't tell her!
Bottom left corner.
Oh, there you are.
Alright.
Where are you, carrot cookie?
Oh, she didn't even exist in my... Oh, is it true?
Does she never exist?
No, no, there is.
Alright, carrot cookie.
I'm gonna find you, carrot cookie.
Where are you?
I'm gonna find... Wait, Tails is not in?
Don't get in here, Tails.
Oh!
Oh, I can't even put... Okay.
Where is she?
Where... Run, carrot cookie!
Run!
Where is she?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
That's right.
I'm gonna throw you in the goddamn pool.
That's what happens to cookies, right?
I'm gonna dissolve you.
That's right.
I'm gonna make you so soggy, no one will love you, carrot cookie.
No one will love you.
A favor sent dead.
There's a black hole?!
Oh!
That's what... You could have been shadow milk.
You could have been shadow milk!
Now into the black hole you go!
Goodbye.
To the shadow realm you go!
No!
She's dead!
Oh, yeah.
How was the sound on the end?
Carrot cookie did nothing wrong.
That was Roger Fugg's favorite cookie!
Try never thinking with a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
Goodbye.
Now let me replace you with a real cookie.
With a real cookie.
Tails.
That's right.
That's a real cookie right there.
My man, Tails.
She was innocent.
That's right.
Tails, my boy.
Tails.
Also this guy.
He looks...
Wait, no.
Is that... That's sort of... That's like me.
Look at that guy.
He's just like me.
He looks just like me.
Alright, nice.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god.
Justice for Carrot Cake.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
I love the intro though.
It's like a little puppeteer.
Collect your pity, you streamer.
Totally.
Oh my god.
I don't think I've ever hit pity before.
I think this is the very first time I've done gotcha streams for four years.
Oh my god.
Today was just not one of those days.
Guys, that's okay.
I take all your bad luck into me.
Today's the day where you donate all the bad luck to me, guys.
And then, and now, now you use my link, guys.
Use my link and download on the description and description and pinned comment.
It'll be, I swear, it'll be so different.
Oh yeah, there's costumes too.
Wait!
Do I have Candy Apple Cookie?
Do I have her?
I don't know if I have Candy Apple Cookie.
She's so cute.
Wait, do I have Candy Apple Cookie?
No?
Alright, we go again.
You always get...
Doki...
Doki walked so the dragons could fly.
It's okay, my luck will change again.
Surely it won't go... Surely!
Surely it's not gonna happen again, right?
Oh man, that'll be...
That'll be way too silly, right, guys?
Wait, is there...
There's no way.
Alright, witch.
Give me those eyes.
Come on.
What have I done?
I don't understand.
What have I done other than banishing Carrot to the Shadow Realm?
What have...
What have I done to you?!
I didn't even burn you yet!
I...
I didn't even burn her!
Wait, I didn't check her eyes.
Oh no, I didn't check her eyes.
I have to watch this.
I...
I didn't...
I didn't check her eyes.
I didn't watch her eyes.
Carrot Cookie was your best friend.
What is this?
Is this?
Wait!
I did it!
Alright, you know what?
Now I definitely know who I wanna send.
Oh my god, and I got...
Oh my god, she's so cute!
Oh my god!
She's like a vampire cookie!
Alright, now I definitely know who I wanna send to the Shadow Realm.
Now, our...
Candy Apple for screenings.
Use this package to make this cookie even.
Alright, where are you?
Where are you?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna find you.
You little shit!
You little...
That's right!
You gave me heart pity!
Why can't you be like her?
Wait, let me... give me a sec.
Before I put you down, I need someone to...
Okay, I need you to be here.
And then...
Let me grab her.
Alright, where are you?
Let me grab you over.
Oh, please!
Alright!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Can I move the chair?
Wait, how do I move the chair?
Guys, this is very important.
This...
Guys...
I need to be able to move this...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Nice, alright.
I'm gonna put this here.
And then, I'm gonna...
Alright.
And now, I'm gonna put this...
I'm gonna put you right here.
Okay, wait.
Oh, no!
Okay, I'm gonna put you...
Oh, my God.
I need this to be right here.
Would you like to place here instead?
Yes.
Okay, now I'm gonna put you right here.
And I'm gonna put you right here.
Alright, perfect.
Okay.
Alright, where are you?
Okay, you watch.
Alright.
Alright!
Wait, I can get another chair.
Give me a sec, wait.
I need more.
Give me a sec, I'm angry.
I need more chairs.
Where are the chairs?
Where are the chairs in this world?
I need more chairs.
Okay.
Yes, where are the chairs here?
There needs to be more seats.
Nobody gives me hard pity.
Oh, no.
This is a show now.
No one gives me hard pity.
In this world.
I already had a bad day.
Chairs where?
How am I supposed to bring...
How am I supposed to...
Oh, wait, we should have this one.
Front row seats.
Right here.
There we go.
Okay, that's one chair.
That's another chair.
Wait, is this...
Does it give me more?
Oh, it gives me more options to look at.
Alright, guys.
Give me a sec, I'm just trying to find more chairs.
Punishing pity is wild.
No one...
This is a lesson to all of you.
You shall never give Doki pity ever again.
Or you know what's gonna happen.
You know what, let's put more.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, there we go.
Now I can have like two.
Okay, and then we need one more.
This is a cat in an event.
You cannot delete.
You cannot delete this account now.
History has been made today.
History has been made.
Alright, nice.
And then I'll buy this.
And I'm gonna put...
Alright, here we go.
Okay.
We'll be removed.
Oh, that's gonna be removed?
Oh, no.
How do I redo that?
Undo.
I like that chair.
That was the original chair.
Oh my god.
I actually really like that particular chair.
I want another one of that chair.
Wait, is this a chair?
Are you a chair?
No, you're not.
Wait, I need to undo so many things.
Okay, wait.
Okay, good.
Okay, we need to keep this chair.
This chair is like the OG chair.
Okay, wait, no.
No.
Oh my god, it's so difficult.
I'm just making a scene here.
You don't understand.
I've been through so much.
Alright, wait, let me move this right here.
So it's like the center, you know?
So like, it's the center of everything.
Okay, let me yoink a different chair.
Let me...
Guys, oh my god.
This is a perf...
Let me yoink a small chair somewhere.
There has to be a small chair somewhere here that I can yoink.
To make it complete.
The center stage.
I just need one small chair.
That's all I need to make this complete.
What is the matter?
Happy 4th year anniversary.
No one gives me hard pity.
I refuse.
I refuse to ever get hard pity ever again.
It's never...
What is this?
I need to duplicate this.
Is it this?
No, that's rotate.
What are you?
Okay, see and shop.
I need another one.
Do I have?
Buy one.
There we go.
Now it's perfect.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god, yeah.
Wait, okay, I'm still buying this.
I'm buying another one too.
Alright.
If I move this, we don't need this house.
Wait.
Get rid of this.
That's not important.
That's...
Get rid of that.
That's not as...
That gives me more space.
That actually...
Oh my god, thank...
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Wait, no.
Yes.
Give me... I don't...
Okay.
Undo.
Here we go.
Now it's perfect.
Now...
Alright.
Alright, everybody, come in here.
For a show.
Get ready for a show, everyone.
I need BTS to be here.
We were so close.
Alright, I'm gonna grab...
I'm gonna...
Is this BTS?
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna grab...
We're gonna grab Tails in here, too.
Tails gotta watch.
He needs to know he can't disappoint me.
Alright, Tails, where are you?
Where are you, Tails?
Woah, that's not what I wanted.
Tails, where are you?
Tails?
Where are you, Tails?
You're here.
You're gonna be in for a show.
Leave them out of it.
Tails, where are you?
I know you're hiding, Tails.
I know you're here somewhere.
They don't deserve this treatment.
Tails...
Oh, you were trying to hide, little guy.
Were you trying to hide?
That's right.
Alright.
Where's BTS?
Where is he?
Woah, is that you?
Who are you?
Oh, that's right.
You're gonna watch this, BTS.
You're in for a show.
Oh, you are definitely gonna be in for a show, Mr. BTS.
Oh, you're gonna run?
No, no.
You're all gonna watch this.
None of you are leaving.
Big Cookie runs safe.
That's right.
No one gives me hard pity.
Alright.
Don't leave.
None of you are leaving.
Alright.
Who else?
Who else am I dragging into this?
They all have to learn.
Oh, Goofy.
It's time.
I'm gonna show you the harsh reality of this world.
Gosh.
Gosh, Mickey.
What's gonna happen to us?
Who else?
Oh, also me.
This is basically me.
I need myself to know too.
Alright.
You think you can leave?
You think you guys can leave?
No.
You guys all get front row seats.
Oh, she's okay.
It was a really bad dream.
Guys, it was just a really bad dream.
She's okay.
It was just...
It was a really bad dream.
Guys.
Guys, it was just a really, really bad dream.
But they're all okay now.
They're all okay.
You are not... Get back on the chair.
Get your ass back on the chair.
I refuse to let you all leave this chair.
You can... That's right.
That's right.
Oh, you guys.
I'm gonna put you back on this chair.
You're not leaving this chair.
That's goddamn right.
Okay, where are you?
The main event.
Oh, you traveled so far.
You...
You walked so far away.
Oh my god.
You thought you could escape?
You really thought you could escape this world?
You really...
Alright, everybody.
Say goodbye.
Never give me hard pity again.
That's right.
You see that?
You all saw that?
You will never give me hard pity.
Away he goes.
That's right.
I deserved all... Now run back to the other cookies and tell them what I did.
That's goddamn right.
Spread the word throughout the kingdoms.
Doki will never get hard pity again.
What is wrong?
I had a really rough day, guys.
I don't know if you guys...
Guys, does it seem obvious that I had a really rough day?
Alright, there we go.
Now they know.
I'm just letting it out on the cookies, guys.
I'm just letting it out on the cookies.
Oh, what happened?
Oh, whoops.
My game crashed.
It was too powerful.
It was too strong.
The shadow milk fought too much crime.
I was like, wait, why did it freeze?
The game was scared.
It's okay.
They think they can kick me out.
I'm back.
They can't kick me out.
That's right.
I totally didn't screen record.
They thought they could kick me out but I'm back.
And my torture chamber, oh it's still here.
My...
My live, my live banishment, my banishment tool is still here.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, no, no, sorry.
My live...
my...
my feels good chamber.
Yes, my feels good chamber is still here.
Yeah.
All right.
But yes.
I had it.
All right.
Let's let's actually let's go back to costumes guys.
Let's go back to costumes.
Wait, which one do I have?
Do I have any of these?
I can't tell.
Gotcha history.
Do I have him?
I don't know.
Or do I have the do I have the royal hanbok and the cozy hanbok?
I mean, wait, are these new?
I don't know if I have them.
How do you tell?
Your own...
How can I... Oh, here you go.
Not found.
Oh, I don't.
I don't have them.
All right, it's time.
Now, now that they saw what I've done, they'll give me everything I want now.
There's no way.
They saw it all.
They've learned.
Wait, how do I... How can I tell if it's... How can I tell if it's like good?
Oh, hey, there's three!
Wait, no.
That's not good.
Oh, don't make me... Don't make me put you... What's your name?
What's your name?
Okay, what?
What?
All right, frost queen cookie, where is she?
What does frost queen cookie look like?
Oh, there you go.
I'm gonna put you here.
Oh.
You better give me... You better not give me pity again.
Oh, you better not.
This will be your fate.
You see this?
I don't know who this kid is, but you see that guy?
That's gonna be you.
All right, so you better get me my costume.
All right, here we go.
Don't worry.
They'll listen now.
If in within 10... If I don't get this within 10 pulls...
Doki, please.
Poor cookie.
Doki, stop.
What is it?
There's no innocent cookies.
There's no such thing as an innocent cookie.
Don't bow to oppression.
Oh my god, five more pulls!
Five more, frost queen.
Five more.
Oh, oh.
Oh, that's not... That looks Halloween themed.
Halloween themed.
The witch's fate of the sweet night.
Oh, but she is pretty.
Oh, it's a witch.
No, it's a goddamn witch.
It's...
I'm done with witches.
Editor isn't gonna be able to use half of this footage.
Simple-minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm done with witches.
Two more.
Are you serious?
Oh,
no, guys.
Yeah, it's not looking so good for the frost witch.
Oh, this is my last pull.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Don't execute her.
Oh, I almost brought you two.
You guys didn't even get anything.
Wait, how did you live?
Back in that portal.
There we go.
It doesn't even know.
All right, where are you?
Oh, you thought you got away?
Oh, sherbert cookie.
Oh, where are you, sherbert cookie?
What do you look like?
You think you are?
You think you're exempt from all of this?
Not once, but twice.
Is this you?
I can always see the warm lights of snowfall village.
Oh, you want to see a war?
I guess you're never gonna see any light no more.
And now you'll never see light again.
And...
At no mercy.
What about you, cotton cookie?
All right, where are you, cotton cookie?
Where are you?
I'll never show.
I'll never show remorse ever again.
I'll never feel ever again.
I'll never...
Nobody can be happy ever again.
Where is she?
What does she look like?
You cannot protect her from her fate.
What's your name?
Is this you?
I'm gonna google your original outfit.
You think you can hide just because I don't know what your default cookie looks like?
Cotton, cotton cookie.
Oh, I know what you look like.
I downloaded your image.
I know what you look like now.
I know.
I got your picture.
No one is safe from her.
I got your picture, you little cookie.
That's right.
Bounty hunted.
I volunteer as tribute for cotton.
No, there's no tributes here.
Only...
only...
this fate.
Oh, you thought... oh!
I believe everyone has a warm...
I don't know.
You thought putting on a different costume?
I reckon...
Goodbye.
She's wrong.
She's... she's just a child.
Hey, nice.
Oh my god.
I fed the vortex so much it's level 10 now.
It's a level 10 black hole.
There's no good in this world.
Not anymore.
The light...
the goodness of my heart has been gone forever.
It's been snuffed out.
The vortex is eating good.
Tonight.
It's been fun so far, guys.
Oh my god.
But yeah, if you guys enjoy seeing me feed cookies into the black hole...
in my feels good chamber, you should check out the game.
You should check out the game and download it yourself.
Pin in my... pin in my...
comments in the chat.
This is not...
You can save the cookies in your own game.
Yeah, but you check out the game.
Um, pin in the chat or in my description below.
All right.
All right, so I'm pretty sure there's like a ton of other new updates.
Uh, what's kingdom affairs?
Oh, it's like... wait, there's like the pavilion of promise?
What's that?
Oh, oh my god, cookie!
I never got him.
I never got you.
Wake up.
Don't make me do it.
I'm already angry.
Don't make...
Wake up.
Come on.
Who are your friends?
And where do they...
If you don't wake up, I'll find your fam.
I'm sorry.
This is sponsored.
I'm so sorry, cookie run.
I'm so sorry.
Please wake up.
You gotta wake up now.
You gotta wake up.
Don't leave him be.
Don't leave him.
Come on.
Oh, it'll be a shame if I find out where your family lives if you don't wake up.
It'll be a shame.
Guys, who are his family?
Who are your... come on.
Oh, there's seven more attempts.
All right, don't worry.
Six more attempts.
Stay asleep.
All right, come on.
Come on.
I'm gonna take them to a special chamber.
My feels good chamber.
Come on.
Last four attempts, little guy.
Last... Oh, you're gonna... Are you gonna give me pity?
Are you really gonna give me pity, too?
You know what happened to the last guy that gave me pity, little guy?
Oh, he doesn't exist no more.
He doesn't need that.
He's trying his best to wake up.
Oh, you didn't want to wake up.
I see.
He...
I'll remember that guy.
I'll remember him.
He saved himself.
It's so over.
Oh, hey, I received a gift.
Wait, I need to change my guy.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec before I do anything.
I gotta change my guy.
I remember how I changed him.
It is like... Is it my cookie?
Yeah.
All right, what do I have?
All right.
What should my new name be?
What should I... No pity.
No!
I wish I could.
Wait.
No!
I got you special characters!
Wait.
Okay, no, that's not threatening enough.
That's not...
I don't know what to do.
I need something that's equally threatening.
I need...
Smile.
There we go.
No pity, smile.
All right.
No pity, smile, cookie.
All right, there we go.
Let's see.
What kind of clothes do I want here?
Huh?
Look around the world is...
How do I... Closet.
There you go.
All right.
Let me go put on some cute... Something cute.
Something... Actually, no.
Something that matches how I feel right now, honestly.
I need something that matches how I... There we go.
Yeah.
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, no.
No, actually, no.
This one works more.
And then...
Yeah, what's his name?
Armor of the Great Destroyer?
Yeah, that sounds about right.
That sounds... Yeah.
That sounds...
That's... That sounds right, you know?
No, I...
I agree.
I agree with that statement.
And then...
Let's see.
If there's Tokio Destroyer...
All right, let's see.
Actually, I like the shoes though.
The shoes are really cute.
I like it.
What's this?
Chocolate?
No, I don't want earrings.
I don't want any earrings on me.
What about wings, gloves?
Oh, what I'm holding!
All right, what do I have?
Yeah, the hammer's nice.
I think a hammer is good.
All right, we'll take the hammer and then...
Then we'll put...
What should we do for hair color?
For hair?
Actually, no, I think... I actually like this hair.
This hair is cute.
Yes, wait, wait, wait.
I like this one.
Wait, what was this?
No.
No, this one works the best.
Yeah.
I'll keep this.
That's gonna be my eyes.
Uh, no, I like the blue more.
No, I like this.
Okay, what's the pilot?
It has to be red.
There we go.
Yeah, and then... No, I like the cookie color.
I think the cookie color is nice.
Save.
Okay.
There we go.
No pity smell is ready to go in.
I'm ready to go back in.
I'm ready.
Wait, did I not save the lips?
No!
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Hello.
Not Doki.
No pity.
The great destroyer is here.
Where are some of the new things around?
Oh my god, wait, I can like...
Yippee!
How do I look at the chat again?
I don't remember.
It's been a while.
Oh, there it is.
A gift has arrived.
Oh, nobody wants to talk to me.
That's fine.
That's that's perfectly fine.
That's...
I don't need to talk to anybody.
All right.
Smile.
This is a quiet town.
It's not threatening at all.
Nope.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm not here to threaten anybody.
I'm just here to hang out with my buddies.
With my buddies everywhere.
See, look at that.
Look at Miko.
I'm such a nice person.
I'm such a...
Wait, how do I... how do I get rid of my chat?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, I'm just strolling around.
Oh, there's so many cute cookie designs.
Oh my god, I forgot about him.
What are you doing here in cookie land?
You're not a cookie.
Wait, who let you in?
She hates us.
Sorry, I'm um, I'm perfectly calm.
I'm in the track.
I'm so nice as she kills.
Oh my god.
I have the paparazzi on me.
I'm famous.
Oh my god.
Look at that.
No pictures.
Dragoons, Angela, crowd, Solif.
No pictures everyone.
I'm a very busy cookie.
Okay, fine one picture.
Okay, fine.
All right.
Watch this.
All right, you can take pictures here.
All right.
Look at that.
Oh, there we go.
That's right.
I'm posing.
Meet and greeted.
That's right.
Yeah, you can take all the pictures you want.
Look at that.
That's right.
Don't worry.
It's like a cosplay shoot right now.
All right.
Yeah.
Work it.
That's right.
Take all the pictures you want guys.
I'm posing for all of you.
Cookie meet and greet.
Yes, I look great.
Literally.
One at a time.
Oh my god.
Oh, wow.
Thank you.
I know I'm famous.
If you guys didn't know, thank you everyone.
Wow.
Thank you.
That's right.
That's me.
Yeah, no pity smile.
The destroyer right here.
Oh, the glorious.
That's me.
Known for being a just and great mayor of my town.
Also, super humble.
That's right.
Don't worry.
Here are some more.
Oh, don't worry.
I'm gonna more poses for all you guys.
That's right.
I better see this on On times 100 magazine right here.
Most influential cookie, um under under Most influential cookie under 100.
There we go.
That's right.
I better be like rank one.
Over here.
What's your opinion on the black hole?
What's your What's your opinion on you sending cookies to the black hole?
I said no comment.
No comment.
No comment whatsoever.
No black person.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Is that the award-winning cookie?
That's right.
What She's dodging the cookie.
The interview is over.
I was I just wanted What what is the next black hole show?
I said no comment.
These allegations Offend me.
Talk to my agent if you want to know more.
That's it.
I'm going home.
How dare I grace you with my presence and you dare ask me about these false accusations about my city The people demand answers No comment whatsoever i'ma claim my prize and leave now do not speak to my client
The allegations, I don't know where they got these fake news about me and my black hole Spoken like a true business There was never a black hole.
Those cookies went on vacation They didn't come they're just on a really really long vacation Mr broken pod, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I'm, technically doki's client and i'm not asking any questions.
They just went to the farm downstate That's right All right, so before um before We almost forgot one of our favorite things about the anniversary.
Wait, what's this?
Oh next stop fourth anniversary festival first time in the station.
Well, the conductor must help Come on, look around all these attractions only you need star jelly coins.
Oh, I have a lot of those I want to free spend a whale and win gifts and more We're to spend the heart.
Ta-da.
This is the special anniversary shop where this steamed cat nip cookie has prepared lots of goodies.
Oh Have you ever been to the anniversary Look, I got a little distracted guys I know I should have been doing this a lot earlier, but you guys don't understand.
I got very distracted about something I can't say what it was.
Um Hahaha
We were busy there were other things that we had to do in cookie run guys.
We were very busy behold the dreaming dice Um the dice.
Yeah, we we made it in the end and lastly the anniversary deluxe Gotcha there you can increase the chance to pull super epic and rare cookies more passengers for me to take care about Well, that's it.
Now.
It's time to have some fun.
Oh Okay Claim I want to do anniversary stuff spin the wheel spin the wheel Spin spin spin No, wait, what's this?
Wait, what is that?
Wait 200 200 coins.
Yeah I got 200.
Wait, that's good, right?
Spare the bear Don't get mad That's good.
That's a jelly coin I got time jumpers.
I'm not i'm not watching an ad.
All right, are you guys watching an ad right now?
Am I?
We even get special train conductor costume, how do I get it here?
Oh, is it this no, I don't have any party hats Milky way cookies.
Where's the train conductor?
Is that it?
What's this milky ways cookies?
One out of one Oh, I can wait I can buy it right now Wait, right.
I don't have it.
Yeah, I have zero.
Wait, let's get fourth anniversary milky.
It's so cute Wait, I don't have the oh no, that's a costume now I have the um, wait, that's a profile picture Oh
It's It's okay guys, I love milky so much.
I just wanna be just like her I just I just want guys.
You don't understand it.
I just wanted to be just like her I just wanted to be just like her guys I just wherever she is Guys I knew it was just a profile picture.
I I just met milky and I just I love her so much that I just I just want to equip it right now, you know, I I I just want to be just like her
That's it guys, I love her so much It's um, am I not done yet?
Wait, I didn't clean I'll clean more Oh, I get to roll dice for free four One, two, three, four.
Yay Oh, I get to roll another one four One, two, three, four.
Yeah, I got pretty crystals now i'm pure Okay, and then what else am I not done yet?
Oh, I haven't done them I haven't done this yet What do I get by unlocking?
I'd like to unlock this No, that seems like a waste of my jelly coins
Oh if I use a stamina jelly I get more coin.
Oh, I see Enemies are closing in.
Oh, there's the fourth.
Wait, they're nearly here and they seem strong These will help you out don't forget to check these often as the rewards get pile Oh, I gotta claim all these rewards.
Oh my god.
That's a lot of them
Whoa, we're stronger now, okay Okay, so I want to do oh event gacha which is oh this is what I did this is basically it's basically the Uh the fourth year anniversary all the fourth year anniversary stuff.
So you get a lot of free things with it, too So there's a limit which one I feel like I spent a lot in general I I feel like I feel like i've already spent.
Oh, and this is a new story, right?
We're at beast yeast Episode seven Spire shadows
Realm of apathy So Determined to find a cure for the mysterious is it Surely, I don't even know what happens in the other chapters to figure out what's going on, right?
The ultimate trial the dark cacao's cookies resolution awaits at the top of the who the heck is dark.
Oh my god guys I don't know Oh, we you have mini recap.
All right, you may be celebrating your little victory for now Oh, I actually skipped everything
Guys if you want to know the context behind this If you want to know the context behind everything just download the game and you can
All right, little sheep Wait, how do we get?
Oh, man, if only we knew how we got here Oh, look, there's a pure vanilla cookie Where'd he go Spoiler free exactly i'm here to give you a spoiler free experience Aha, there you are.
Come on.
It's time to go.
I love the voice acting for this.
It's so like it's so cute Let me check.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, is that shadow milk?
Huh?
Those eyes Why are you a sheep know them from somewhere?
Oh my god evil sheep
Evil ba That's only a dream a memory from my childhood Your vanilla cookie Are you unwell?
Oh, she's so pretty I'm fine.
Thank you.
I must have nodded off a moment there evil
How come I have to read off pure vanilla is it because i'm her i'm him We can't afford to rest not now.
We must find it the beast binding ritual.
Yes, you're right There has to be a trace A mention of the witch's magic tucked away somewhere among all these scrolls This kingdom is the very oh, that's why oh, that makes sense.
I was like it's weird if there are any records left They have to be here A green let's keep searching i'll look in this section then i'll inspect these rows But are you truly?
All right You look concerned Don't worry, it was just a bad dream Haha My childhood was full of happy memories.
Why does this dream trouble me so All we need is a clue to point us in the right direction to the binding ritual anything tap tap tap White lily cookie I must be hearing things Who's there he went that way Okay, wow, her voice is a little his voice is a little different Sorry,
the voice actor had a cold I had a chamber Wait, okay.
Wait all these books in ancient magic chronicles of old and Oh, I think I found it And thus the all devouring heart of darkness Now she's
Rituals of the witches the man's okay the great Oh my gosh, no, I can't it doesn't even register the the beast binding rich.
Oh my god doesn't register me anymore The man agreed
It must be conducted by someone who is
too close Far and out of reach For you are forbidden from meddling with magic beyond you can Now the spire of all knowledge stands without a master Where all knowledge began and there shall remain as long as there is light Yeah, who dares lay hand on the forbidden knowledge?
After many hardships may you find the answer you seek The master of the spire It's about chattel milk cookie without a doubt He could be there awaiting me Without a doubt haven't gained a physical form.
He will pose a great much greater threat Our encounter can't be avoided no matter if I fear it or not The beasts are regaining their form and power all the more reason to face them and put an end to their evil For the good of all cookies and of the entire world We must be prepared to fight our bravery and our hope will become our greatest weapons in the war but for now My mission is to learn everything about the ritual Okay,
nice, all right time to do our first fight is this one right um How do I have you Oh Okay, sorry guys before I do my fight I didn't realize something very important Oh you thought you could fool me you little ferret You thought you were awake this entire time.
You were awake this entire time
How dare you I try to wake you up bts.
Look at this You should have stayed asleep you should have slept.
Okay.
Anyway back to our story guys, all right All right, I should want to change my team.
How do I change my team?
Uh
How do I change it I don't want to change my team I shouldn't have given you a taste of power Hahaha
Oh ready click the ready, okay.
All right edit Get out of my team get out of my team uh It's fine.
We don't need these guys.
You know who we do need I know who we need.
All right My boys
I can only play one bts.
What's the point?
What's the point I can only place one i'm just gonna put them all in i'm just gonna
Sad all right, I guess i'll put one of you i'll put one of my Sonic and hedgehog and bts That's right They're not fighters they're lovers and then i'll also put in you know what else i'm gonna put it in I'll put in my boy Uh, where are you?
Oh, where the heck are you?
It's not the same No They're gonna die.
No, they're not They're not i'll put one good.
Okay.
Look i'll put this guy.
There's no way There's no way they'll die now.
There's no way.
I can't believe it.
I can't I forgot.
I can't make the disney characters fight I was gonna put i was gonna put goofy in here, too What is this and then i'll put in a furry too, you know Put in a furry here This is optimal team comp right there sonic tails one one One k-pop idol a god and a furry
What what more can I ask for you guys What what a team All right, and then one.
Oh, wait, there we go.
Yeah.
There you go.
What a team a solid team There we go That should be good, right?
There's no way I could lose with this right, I mean I have a million A million power.
There's a clear reason why you keep hitting hard There we go You still equip toppings.
You wished it.
No, they don't need it You might miss as your would you like to start?
Yeah Let's go What's there we go, this is that dream team right there My friends I'm grateful that you agree to a journey with me to the spire of all knowledge I'm creating a team.
I'm creating it.
I'm assembling a team guys Don't mention it pure vanilla cookie.
That's what friends are for.
Am I right?
Exactly.
You can count on us Yeah, we'll follow you anywhere pure vanilla cookie caramellion Cookie say what?
There's a cure.
Oh, it's so cute.
It's like a chameleon So sonic tails and bts walked into a forest and bumped into a furry and a god That place is weird if I were you i'd go in the opposite direction No The book said the secret of the anti-beast magic is kept there in that tower in that tower Yes,
if there is a place to hold the secret the binding ritual is the spire the main of shadow milk cookie Yes, that's right.
What awaits us there?
Let's be careful Don't worry white lily cookie Don't let your guard down pure vanilla cookie Look at the team.
We have white lily cookie.
How can we fail?
caramellion cookie You What a badge.
Okay.
Here's what he looks like He's so cute.
I like the I like the I love the color And the eyes for it And it's quiet too quiet.
All right Let's go I believe Oh, wait, we'll do auto.
Oh my god.
I can't oh my god.
Am I winning am I?
Am I guys I think i'm winning oh I told you guys look at that Look at that.
I wonder who's carrying this team right now.
It has to be bts, right?
Wow what happened
Maybe i'm not sure I knew it it has to be bts Oh,
I like her Her like little like hair buns or apples You wanna join us Your bravery saved our kingdom and I wanted to repay this debt Into the spire.
Oh, she's cute.
It's a place unlike any other a magnificent yet dreadful place I can help you.
You'll see a guide Well, that's just what we needed Exactly.
We're getting lost It's very kind of you apple fairy cookie.
Your help is most welcome You don't know what dangers await us while we're headed stay close and be vigilant at all times That's right I trust her.
She has apples as ears I did it.
Oh so easy Look at that Look at that guys.
I told you i'm assembling a team.
I told you Hahaha Oh my god easiest fight of my life and that is called pure Optimization that that was hard mode.
I don't know if you guys noticed that but that was hard mode right there I just made it look so easy that you guys couldn't tell that was hard mode.
I You guys just couldn't tell all right now is my favorite part of this game Shifting balance new season My favorite part.
This is where the real gaming starts.
All right Are these the babies All right.
Let's see All right.
Oh, I won't fight this guy.
She has a carrot Guys who will win?
Wait, I I think I can make a bigger team
I'm pretty sure I can make a strong There Yeah, that should be 2 million now.
That should be more.
Oh, yeah, there we go There I I feel like you know, three two million is a little I feel like two million might be like two weeks So like I gotta add an extra million in there I gotta add an extra.
What's your name?
I'm gone.
Toki versus copy.
Maybe Let's let's play catch Let's play catch
Did we win look at all these
Yippee, yeah, we got it for safety measures, you know Just for like Tokida destroyer is here Oh I'm here.
Oh you have a carrot You know what?
Let me double check if i'm gonna double check my cookies to make sure they're all you know I'm a little worried.
I won't be sure my cookies are well prepared.
Let me double check to see if they're all leveled up What happened Guys, I gotta make sure are my cookies Are they all are they all okay?
Do they need more food?
Don't work cookies I'm here to feed you and make you strong Oh, you can't be stronger Wait a minute Okay All right.
What was my lineup?
What was my lineup again?
Who are my guys?
Okay, okay, let me Let me all right, let me double check real quick.
Are these guys the strongest in my lobby?
Are they All right, they're the strongest right these guys All right, let's see Go copy the top teams.
All right, who are the top teams?
Give me your leaderboard.
I'm gonna i'm gonna become you Okay, let's see uh Uh I want to be sure I need to make sure you're all okay The original team you had was better but at the power level the hall of fame, okay, where's the hall of fame?
I'm gonna become them Hall of fame ranking That's me All right, i'm gonna take your team How do I take your team i'm gonna become you Okay How do I copy their team guys, this is very important top left Where is it?
Oh memorize it.
We have to memorize it Oh, I have to remember these cookies Okay All right, guys, there's flame and then there's shadow and then there's that and then there's the pink one and then the Black okay the pink one and the black one, okay um All right, guys Guys,
I really need to beat these guys.
They look very scary.
Give me Yes, all right, we gotta take him out Take him out right remove you Remove you remove you And then it was like What where are you what do you look like?
What do you look like it was the pink one and then the uh use only shadow milk Shadow milk is level one right now Start the cookies by rarity.
Oh, okay Um, oh here you go.
Oh this girl I remember this one And but you are where's the pink one I don't remember what the pink one looked like again What does she look like?
Oh, she has a yellow background.
Okay.
Where's the yellow background?
Wait, what?
Don't worry i'll level her i'll level.
Oh my god, where is she?
Where is she?
She was pink.
Was it this pink one?
What's your name?
Who are you?
No, that's shining litter wrong pink one wrong Wrong.
Oh, she's all the way downstairs.
Why are you downstairs?
I thought you were rare May the crunchiest win is it you No, i'm, sorry all the pink ones got me confused that's not you Oh Snap dragon snap dragon, but what if I just put Let me just put a you know what i'm gonna put you in here i'm gonna
All the gods in the world And bts mpt.
No, I think I think this one's I I All the gods in the world I know I saw it snap dragon and then I was like, no, I won't put it.
I want to put him in here I realize it's a better matchup.
I realized it was just better um I need to level up.
There he is.
All right, be strong
Max here we go Yeah Well, that's the biggest oh, I don't have enough.
All right, there you go now you're strong now you're strong All right, where am I other this one warrior must not be all right level up that's right Nice Now you're strong.
Oh, I can awaken you.
Oh, I can't I can't I don't have enough skill powder.
What's that?
How do I do the skill powder we're skill powder Is it this oh, I didn't level up his skills like these.
Oh I did it.
Okay.
I got it.
That's it, right?
All right, and then him and then are you leveled up yet No.
All right.
Don't worry.
I got you leveled up And then max level there we go.
Oh my god, it's so easy being good at this game
Damn oh and there you have it level 86 Okay, let me find my bts boy real quick he's gonna be the strongest bts boiler is That's right Get over there Oh, I'm already here That's it.
That's all I could.
That's all right.
Never mind.
He's just gonna be level 50.
He's just Gonna be love.
All right Now I should be strong enough to fight him Now Now I should be strong enough guys I hope I can do it.
I'm so scared I'm so scared.
I hope I could win against him.
I
Oh my god
I think it's very fair Look at him go Did I win?
Oh my god The fight's not I like how the fight keeps going It's like please he's already dead Why are we still fighting
Oh my god, it got to level two.
Oh my god guys I got to level two.
I'm gonna fight this guy because Isn't that so sad?
He put his best team here.
Oh you have 231 wins Oh That's so cute Now get this jokey the destroyer is here i'll do my best heart please satisfy That's right That's right You might be dead but i'm still gonna keep going I wish I could stay in the low elo too.
I'm jokey but no take me back down there Take me back down there I wanna stay down there.
Take me back I wanna fight them.
Oh, you're 200.
Oh a million 600 Oh, that's cute You think you're so strong But the team is so strong and you really think so My god you put all you spend so much money You really think your little team is stronger
Wait, wait, no, can I actually lose?
There's no way my power level is stronger.
There's no way Yeah, yeah, goodbye Oh Isn't that cute?
Oh, you thought you're little Your team would you spend so much money on is stronger than my team that's fucking right That's why you deserve to be in that.
You know, that's That's okay, right They put this team here and then like no one's ever gonna beat us up.
Oh you too.
Oh, you have the snow queen level 54 54 Get over here Get over here no pity smile No pity, oh I killed myself too.
Yes I await our next.
Yeah, we did it.
We love Rinka
There we go Nice.
Oh my god.
Hey, it's getting a little harder now guys Wow That's a little harder Not hard enough get over here.
Let's fast forward because I know i'm going to win anyway
That's right nothing can beat me And That's right.
I knew I was gonna win so badly That like I didn't even give them the pleasure of me watching me destroy them.
You know what?
You don't even let that's right I don't even need to watch you anymore That's how I know i'm strong enough.
Oh, you know i'm gonna beat up the small guy, too i'm gonna beat up the Just cold as ice That's right I'm tier three I'm silver two now How are my games easier silver two?
How are you know what?
What is this 269?
Oh, I can't consist of a seat.
Oh, okay eyes on the prize team eyes on the prize That's right
He's just sings don't There's no oh it's it's actually just that easy it's just It's just that I just don't even oh my god, there he is.
He's back go sing sing for your life Area
It's just that easy Oh, you're trying to tell me that shout I can make anything work I don't need shadow milk.
I can make anything work with this team.
Watch this Where is he where is he?
Where's my boy tails?
Where's my boy tails and sonic Looks like fun.
I calculate a disaster.
All right, what's my power level?
You think just because you really think I have shadow milk crutch think again Okay fight that okay, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa calm down guys calm down guys We don't need to get ahead of ourselves here we don't That's right I don't need shadow milk And honestly even the super chat,
thank you.
Thank you.
That's right.
I can make anything work Even shadow and sonic and tails.
That's right You think i'm scared?
Let me avoid all the 2 million teams right first.
Let me oh I can't Oh, okay Oh, I could pay to you.
Don't you think?
You think you could stop me from beating up children in game?
That's right I spent my gems to keep going
That's right, you can't stop me I spent my gem so I could still go
That's right Let's do that again sometime She's on her villain.
You can't stop tails and sonic So talented Of course son I gotta re-watch this what happened There's no way there's three of us
There's no way What happened How did you die you were so close oh my god this son no keep singing
Keep singing keep singing Oh my god, that is bullshit They actually cc'd me By seven hp.
They actually oh, that's it.
That's it.
Where is he?
No, I can't fight you I can't fight you.
What's your name?
Okay, i'm fine.
Oh Can I find players?
In in my game i'm gonna friend them.
I'll remember
I Wrote his name down.
I'm gonna add you
Into the boy, I got you.
I got your name
Hey guys anyway guys um That was fun.
That was really fun.
It's supposed to be one hour stream, but I I was enjoying it so much guys.
I um, I was definitely Enjoying it a lot and I had a great time.
Um checking out all the new updates in uh And the fourth year anniversary for cookie run kingdom again like a huge shout out to cookie run uh for sponsoring me again and uh And letting me check out all the new updates all the fourth year anniversary Items that came out today.
Um, is there I don't think I don't know if i'm missing anything, but feel free to let me know if I am Missing anything in the fourth year anniversary Um, but if not Uh, it was a very fun time.
Thank you again for the sponsor.
Um And please if you guys haven't already please check out the link in the description and in the chat and pin in the chat Um to support me and cookie run kingdom so it supports the stream a lot if you click on the link and download the game um as Always everybody Uh,
if you guys want to check out more of the new content Uh, please feel free to download the game and explore the whole world of cookie run kingdom because there's actually so much to do there Um, there's always there's so much free things you can get.
There's a lot of like, um, it's very Uh friendly towards new players.
So and honestly the designs are great and the story seems really interesting as well So yeah, thank you everybody Um as always everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that Blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it as always everyone I'll see you guys next time everybody Bye guys